anticipándose a las propuestas de la
unión europea londres puso este martes
sus cartas sobre la mesa lo que busca
prácticamente es cambiar modificar
completamente este protocolo de irlanda
del orden que el tribunal europeo de
justicia no tenga jurisdicción es decir
que no sea el árbitro de las partes algo
que ya bruselas ha negado porque sería
saltarse una de sus líneas rojas pero
además busca que se acabe con la
burocracia para que puedan ingresar
productos a irlanda del norte- y que por
ejemplo algunos alimentos como las
salchichas que no cumplen con los
estándares de la unión europea puedan
ingresar sin problemas esta noche el
gobierno británico ha dicho que debe
darse cambios significativos que aborden
el corazón del protocolo y una solución
que todas las partes respalden en el
futuro y protejan el acuerdo de
1998 el acuerdo de paz y es que desde el
primero de enero de este año cuando se
hizo efectivo el divorcio con bruselas
prácticamente que enviar un producto
desde cualquier ciudad británica e
irlanda del norte que es el mismo país
es considerado un tipo de export porque
esta región irlanda del norte se
mantiene dentro del mercado único de la
unión europea y también de su sistema de
aduanas esto se hizo para evitar el
regreso de las fronteras físicas que
pusieran en riesgo el acuerdo de paz
desde ya se prevé que las negociaciones
entre londres y bruselas que deben
empezar en las próximas semanas serán
tan difíciles y largas como lo fueron
las del break sin el acuerdo en general